we always say
uh the definition of good whiskey is
whiskey you like
full stop right and
the right way to drink it is however you
want
second stop and the right glassware is
one that doesn't leak
that's all
now you will
find whiskey professionals will always
have water
a water back with whiskey and they'll
add it in increments to sort of open up
and and uh access what's in there
so yeah that's very common i've been
with billy who
the entire time that i've known him has
had a little couple of dashes of water
in his whiskey i've been with billy on
nights out where when he's put water in
his whiskey people have gone no no what
are you doing billy said that's how
you're supposed to drink whiskey and
they've gone no that's sacrilege that's
sacrilege i guess it's different in
different parts of the world right but
as a scotsman telling a scotsman how to
drink whiskey is a little cheeky
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy
[Music]